يمكنني أن أعلن أن الحزب البرلماني
لديه ثقة
[موسيقى]
يمكنني الإبلاغ بصفتي ضابطًا عائدًا
أن 359
بطاقة اقتراع لم يتم الإدلاء بأصواتها
الفاسدة أن التصويت
لصالح الثقة في مسرح بوريس جونسون
كان 211 صوتًا وكان التصويت
ضد 148 صوتًا
[موسيقى  ]
لذلك أعتقد أن هذه نتيجة جيدة جدًا
للسياسة وبالنسبة لأه بالنسبة للبلد
فقط ، فأنا أفعل فقط بهذا
المعنى وأعتقد أنها
نتيجة مقنعة لما تعنيه أنه
يمكننا أن نتحرك كحكومة  التركيز
على الأشياء التي أعتقد أنها تهم الناس حقًا
[الموسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يمكننا التركيز على ما نقوم به لمساعدة
الأشخاص في تكلفة المعيشة
مع ما نفعله لمسح الأعمال
المتراكمة التي تغطيها  نحن
نقوم بجعل الشوارع والمجتمعات أكثر أمانًا من خلال
وضع المزيد من رجال الشرطة في
الخارج ويمنحنا الفرصة
لمواصلة التوحد لرفع المستوى
لتقوية اقتصادنا
أنت